now skinnies understands that there are
no Asylum Seekers left at the
controversial monster processing center
in Kent this is after a moment 6 000
people were transferred to hotels our
political correspondent Liz Bates is in
Westminster uh now we know that the
center was over capacity Liz it could
handle around a thousand people over a
24-48 hour period but why is everyone
had to go
uh well yes you're right overcrowding
just one of the problems uh that has
come up recently when it comes to the
manston Asylum Center causing the
government problems in the Home
Secretary for weeks now because uh first
of all of that issue of overcrowding but
also reports emerging of just appalling
conditions that the people that are
being processed there have been
subjected to outbreaks of infectious
diseases including diphtheria and even
over the weekend uh it emerged that
there had been a death of a man over
staying there at this currently an
investigation into that and of course
amid all that accusations from Human
Rights activists and Charities and
opposition politicians that this Center
was simply not fit for purpose and I
think for the government uh the problem
that it was becoming a symbol really of
a a broken Asylum system more broadly
and really a failure despite uh years
now of tough rhetoric on this issue of
just failing at the government failing
really to get a grip of this properly
now the news today that this Center is
now empty the prime minister's official
spokesman has said about that well by
Design manston is a temporary holding
facility you would expect numbers to be
low on a daily basis so what they're
saying is that this is normal they would
expect numbers of people to be moving
through here there is an ongoing legal
challenge to the government on this
issue and that's been brought by among
others the charity detention Action Now
what they have said in response to this
news is the Home Secretary has only
taken steps to address failures at
manston after our
urgent legal Challenge and widespread
public condemnation so what is clear is
that now that this sent this Center is
empty it takes the kind of immediate
pressure off the Home Secretary when it
comes to this Center in particular but I
think what is also clear is that there
will be more to do for the government
for the home office to address the wider
concerns that have been raised because
of the issues particularly to manston
when it comes to their approach
generally and their treatment of
people's healing cycle seeking Asylum
here in the UK Liz thank you Liz boats
for the latest there on that story from
Westminster